Adam GaSe here on the program how are
you coach I'm good how you doing I'm
doing fine is this the first time you've
got glad you throw in the Michigan thing
what is that I mean just cuz I was born
in Ypsilanti doesn't mean you have to
associate it with Michigan well it's
down the street University of Michigan
like its I know you want to throw that
in there so bad well I mean hey at least
we're hey we're in the Final Four that's
all you see when you say what do you say
Eastern Michigan cuz that's where that's
the time you were born okay
the Michigan State the Michigan State
hey what did you think when you saw Izzo
and involved in that whole brouhaha that
he was coaching his kid too hard as a
coach what do you think of that
Adam Dalton I mean uh I was a freshman
in college in his second year so that
that just looked like another game to me
he's not right just the fact that you
know he coaches he coaches those guys
hard and the guys that he recruits to
that program
those guys are built different and they
to me I mean to me I think they expected
from him and you could see that from him
and the rest of the players that they
that they expected it and they didn't
think that this was too much although
that they did try to calm him down at
one point in time and he he expected
that from them to it looked actually
healthy to me even though I might not be
that when you when you go back through
time and you look at some of those games
where he gets fired up you you see guys
like draymond Green and some of those
other guys kind of grabbing him and kind
of trying to calm him down every once
while I mean it happens every few years
you kind of see something like that I've
never thought it was a big deal because
those kids those kids had trusted them
they they they believe in them and and
they've always they've gone to battle
for him right those guys they do it
different there is this the first
extended time you've had in the in the
New York City area in New York
metropolitan area I'm just knowing where
you've been in your life in your career
is your first time in this little area
no way yep pretty much I rod I lived in
outside of Philly for three years but
that's that's as close as I can get it
so you know that people don't stop for
pedestrians here like they do in the
state of Michigan right they don't they
just keep going I don't haven't driven a
whole bunch of places so oh my gosh in
New Jersey there's those jug handles -
you got to be careful with that coach
seriously these are really yeah there's
strange that um not gonna be going very
far I got a lot of things on
my plate right now I bet I'm worried
about getting ready for draft and then
season okay well in terms of season
right around the corner is the the day
you next Monday where you open up the
doors and the players come in how much
contact have you been able to have with
Sam darn 'old so far nothing I mean once
once Monday comes and then we're able we
got four hour window there two hours of
strengthen conditioning two hours of
meetings so you move as quickly as you
can for you know four days a week for
two weeks and then it moves in different
phase where you can do some stuff on the
field so there your time in the spring
is limited you just try to cram as much
in as you possibly can and and kind of
see what sticks and then you start over
once you hit training camp has he had
your playbook
has he added at the very least well I
mean for us we're you know we have to
make some adjustments to the PlayBook we
there's a lot of things that we have to
really kind of change some verbage
things and stuff like that so I don't
even know if we can get them playbook
but he doesn't have one yet are you like
the rest of the coaches in the league
that I'm hearing about that think the
restrictions that you have placed on you
with your players this time of year is
too restrictive and this was a topic at
the owners meeting last week well it is
what it is right now I mean we're in the
we're in the CBA and these are the rules
and I know every everyone I mean you can
complain all you want but it doesn't do
anything so really it's about maximizing
the time when you have your players
available to you you know it's kind of
on their on their own a little bit where
you've got to hope that guys want to do
as much as they can outside the building
you know if the next one comes around I
think guys have kind of made suggestions
of what they think would be reasonable
to change but I still think that it
feels like a long ways away before we
kind of get to that Adam GaSe head coach
of the New York Jets here on the Rich
Eisen show what can levy aunt Belle do
in your offense Adam well he I mean he
can he does all three phases as far as a
running back goes he you know run the
ball catch the ball you know being able
to
protect I think his ability to work out
of the backfield or you know as an in a
receiver position as a receiver are
unique especially for a guy his size
with his ability to run after the catch
he's a hard guy to bring down I mean
there's so many I mean it's so it's a
well document I mean the guy's done
things that not many running backs or
even probably I mean they're nobody's
really done what he's done as far as
total lion guards from scrimmage and
things like that so I think really for
us it's gonna be about just bringing him
along he's learning a new system and you
know it's we're just gonna keep feeding
him stuff and we'll see kind of how far
we can take it with him gear one is part
of the reason why he was acquired that
he went to Michigan State Adam is that
the way it goes that that could be a
possible reason that was the determining
factor right that that is really good
that and he is really really good so I
imagine are you gonna have a tug-of-war
with yourself over how much to use him
obviously with him not having played at
all last year what's your concern level
on on that well I I don't really see it
as a concern because I mean we're
starting here in April he's I mean for
him he's just been working out all year
long and I think he's just ready to kind
of get back doing some of the football
things which really we can't really do
the type of things that he's probably
looking forward to do till you know May
and once we kind of get to that part we
can kind of start getting on the field
and then having practice I think those
are the things that he'll probably enjoy
getting back to I mean we'll be smart
especially early just kind of you know
figure out what the right rhythm is for
him and it'll be the same thing once we
carry in the training camp he's had a
lot of touches over his career he has
you know experience playing in that
position to where he knows what he needs
to get ready for the season and really
that's the key to everything you know
it's it's similar to what at least we've
done in the past with backs that have
been through you know multiple seasons
where you communicate with them they let
you know this is the best thing for me
to get ready for the season and you kind
of you listen to those
because they know their bodies best they
know what they need to get ready Adam
GaSe here on the Richardson show did you
OH
doo doo doo doo Jilla diligence easy for
me to say did you do due diligence with
darn 'old with the Dolphins did you did
you look at him coming out of USC bring
him in interview him have him on the
board at the combine anything like that
I mean we talked him at the combine we
didn't we didn't spend a lot of time on
him we thought that he was going we
thought he was gonna be the first pick
but we thought he'd be long gone before
we you know we ever had an opportunity
so he was one of the guys that had me
look at they had me you know we thought
maybe Baker or Josh Allen or Josh Rosen
one of those three would be back by us
we never thought Sam was gonna fall to
fall that far okay and you thought it
would possibly possible the Baker fell
to you at that spot back in the day well
when we started when we started the
process he would you know he didn't have
as much traction as he got as the
process went on and seemed like he
picked up some steam as the draft kind
of process you know the longer it went
so what did you forward to the Johnson
family in the interview process about
darn 'old obviously that was the that's
the the crown jewel of the offensive
staff right there to to have in your
hands what was the game plan that you
forward it if you don't mind revealing
that the biggest thing that we talked
about was just kind of the development
of him making sure that we win a win
about the offense the right way with him
instead of treating him like he'd been
in the league 15 years and put it all on
his plate uh-huh how did we basically
take his development from year one going
in and year two kind of the process that
we were going to take going forward to
make sure that he developed the right
way you know this is the first time that
I've had a quarterback at this stage of
his career a lot of the guys that I've
had have been in five six 15 so it's
been guys with a lot more experience so
this is kind of a different way about
going about things with him and just
kind of bringing him along and seeing
how much you know really sticks for him
and
what were what we can do with him you
know what we can take off his plate so
that's not on on him every game to kind
of deal with certain things and I feel
like heading into the spring we have a
good game plan and what we'll kind of
see how that goes and we know that we
just need to be flexible yeah I mean
he's obviously a guy that the whole the
whole city of New York that loves the
green and white is just putting
everything in his basket right now and
he seems to be able to handle it I mean
again you're saying you really haven't
spent much time with him right I mean at
this point in time like any room with
job I mean he's been he's been out west
for the most part he's had to come back
here a couple times just to make sure
that you know always any injuries that
he had last year you know he's all
cleaned up and ready to go and you know
so any time I've seen him it's been very
very quick and brief and more of him
stopping in you know all my interactions
with him have been I've really been
impressed with him just trying to his
his demeanor the way he carries himself
it's you know I'm looking forward to
kind of getting this thing going next
Monday all right Adam GaSe Jets head
coach couple more minutes left with him
here on our first of three shows from
New York City you know I would ask you
about the draft but I just feel you
probably wouldn't tell me anything
anyway so I'm just gonna give you this
opportunity you want to use my show as a
smokescreen put something out there you
don't really mean oh I got nothing rich
nothing you want I'm a Michigan State
basketball I'm all for it I mean I'm I'm
happy to do that
I could tell you it hurts you doesn't it
you know what do you guys make the
tournament this year yes we made the
tournament we made the sweet 16 and the
team that brought us nothing but misery
no the team that brought us nothing but
misery is a team that you're gonna be
facing this coming up and by the way I
am rooted for Michigan State because I
love is oh and I hate Duke as much as I
love is even more than I hate I love is
oh I hate Duke I don't know why I just
have an irrational hatred dislike for
Duke I was a good game I know that oh we
could talk Cassius Winston a little bit
here but you I'm serious I'm offering my
platform to you to put something out
there that would actually help the New
York Jets in the draft
you wanted to see us I have nothing for
you you got a book I'm focused on we're
we're gonna we're gonna start our draft
meetings here you know
pride tomorrow I think okay that's
that's when we're scheduled to get this
thing going right you know we go through
our process with the coaching staff
these guys have been working on this for
a year
yep and you know for us it's really we
get a chance to have our input our
opinions and then we'll mike really has
to kind of organize this thing and kind
of set it up or for draft day and then
you know we really have to get our
players going well it's it's a crazy
time of year because you're working with
your guys you're dealing with the draft
it's just a lot going on all at the same
time and I think being first year
program it this is the one where coaches
have to do a good job of giving our
input but at the same time we've got to
make sure that we have great focus on
the current players we have right now
well I thought that was really well put
Adam you didn't even use the words best
we're just gonna take the best player
available that could have been your out
right there and the question I'm very
you know I I thought you could have gone
that way you didn't so I appreciate that
you know yeah I mean I don't even know
what that means anymore you know you
know you could you could be it's funny
how the best player available always
seems to give me the guy you need it
does isn't that amazing how that works
out that one all right so then let me
ask you this last one for you since
you're not gonna obviously draft a
quarterback third overall Kyler Murray
his game can't work in the NFL at five
foot ten and eight
Adam GaSe Sevier watch him play I have
when you think he's pretty good I think
he's dynamic I think he gets rid of the
ball before he gets hit but sometimes
players can arrive a lot faster in the
National Football League that's true but
I think I also look at it as when you
you're a player that is played at the
the school he played at you look at his
offensive line the success he's had
against the teams he's played I mean
he's played some some really good teams
you know it's hard to predict success on
any quarterback coming out you can you
can say this we think this guy is going
to be good but you really don't know
until they get here
but you know I think you know as time
has gone on you know the height thing
people are moving away from it seems
like I mean everybody's seeing what
Russell Wilson has done you know hi I
was lucky enough to watch that first
hand in the Super Bowl and you know it's
I think that's kind of going away either
some guys can do it and some guys can't
so if people think that a guy can do it
and he has the skillset that you're
looking for as far as arm strength and
making all the throws and being able to
go through progressions and good pocket
presence and movement you know an
ability to run the football I think guys
can have success in this league all
right coach appreciate the time and good
luck with the uniform release that I
think is tomorrow right I mean I'm sure
you've got your finger on that pulse as
well right the new uniforms that's what
I heard okay okay that's it tomorrow
it's tomorrow good luck with that good
luck on Saturday against Texas Tech and
should you advance just make sure that
there's no there's no meeting schedule
on Monday night for the national
championship game just trying to plan it
all out for you we'll have to cancel our
meetings on Monday here we go there may
be an iron-rich and Eisen and Michigan
but I'm a team player when it comes to
you I'm glad rich I'm glad that we're
converting you not converting me but
that's okay I understand
I love is oh and I'm rooting for you
rich you want to win and I get it yeah
it's okay well I mean certainly it I'm
looking forward to green and white wins
Sundays Mondays and Thursdays and maybe
the occasional Saturday for the National
Football League that's all I'm looking
for but you knew that already that's
what we're working on okay very good
coach thanks for the time appreciate it
all right red all right brother thank
you that's Adam GaSe everybody the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience